les pointes quand vous mettez votre
couvercle vous regarder si par exemple
il faut un petit peu les redescendre et
tout pour pas que ça écrase hockey les
cuisines du cfa de blois en retrouver
l'effervescence d'un vent confinés par
les herbes à vérifier qu avait partout
autour du chef étoilé rémy giro les
apprentis cuisiniers se sont appliqués à
préparer des plats haut de gamme pour
les étudiants en difficulté comme ceux
céleri en croûte feuilletée étant donné
que les restaurants sont fermés
quand on n'est pas au cfa on ne fait pas
grand chose une classe ça fait du bien
de pouvoir travailler tous ensemble avec
des chefs en plus très connu ça fait
plaisir qu'on à faire un travail de
brigade qu'on n'a pas l'habitude donc
c'est très intéressant et puis la
fabrication de la pâte feuilletée parce
qu'on a fait différemment que d'une pâte
feuilletée classique et plein d'autres
plats qu'on a découvert on semble
aujourd'hui vous avez tous les yeux
grands ouverts ils étaient tous motivés
et ils savent pourquoi ils le font ils
ce soir ça va être cesser ces apprentis
qui vont remettre ça aux étudiants il ya
aussi une question de de moralité de
lien social
on est très fiers de le faire et on est
surtout fier que nos jeunes il retrouve
un petit peu d'espoir au travers cette
action en espérant pouvoir là la
renouveler plusieurs croient ce projet a
été monté rapidement par l'association
des disciples escoffier présidée par le
chef rémi giro le rotary-club loiret
château et le cfa ils ont sollicité
leurs fournisseurs pour obtenir des
produits de qualité à cuisiner résultat
à la halle aux grains de blois cet
après-midi 280 repas ont été distribués
aux étudiants éligibles à l'aide
alimentaire
ça change du surgelé qu'on est obligé
d'acheter parce que c'est tout ce qui
est abordable pour nous si on voit plus
on sent vite du budget
ouais de la bouffe cuisine et ça fait du
bien ça nous change je me sens n'a même
pas trop le temps de nous mêmes de
cuisiner avec les examens et tout ça
donc c'est plutôt sympa au total 140
étudiants ont pu bénéficier de cette
opération solidaire
une opération que le chef rémi géraud
souhaiterait réaliser dans les cinq
autres départements de la région
bon